imagine you're getting ready to go to
the gym you grab your keys in your bag
and then you take a supplement and you
feel like it's working it might be
working a little too well what you don't
know is that this supplement one that
you bought at the health aisle at your
grocery store is laced with an anabolic
steroid an illegal drug invisibly mixed
into this powder in recent years
researchers have been grabbing thousands
of different supplements off the shelf
and testing them to see what's inside
and what they found in over 3,000
supplements that they tested is that 28%
had some sort of illegal substance
mostly steroids meaning the people that
are taking them are unintentionally
doping in another study 92% of the
supplements that were tested by
scientists were contaminated with
bacteria 87% had fungal
contamination and when they tested CBD
supplements they found that 55% of the
oils had either way more or way less CBD
than stated on the label and a few of
them even had THC in them the thing that
gets you high and it turns out the
government here in the United States
doesn't seem to care so how did we get
here and why are shady companies
influencer campaigns and targeted
advertisements selling Americans things
to put in their body that aren't what
they say they are and that are
potentially dangerous and I guess a big
question for me is which of these are
actually necessary or healthy and which
of them are dangerous and is this all
just a waste of
[Music]
money hey pause really quick you know
how we started this video with like this
hypothetical scenario that like I'm
drinking like workout supplements well I
actually do workout now for the first
time in my adult life I am like kind of
buff the sponsor of today's video is the
reason why thank you co-pilot for
sponsoring the video this is like a game
changer co-pilot is a platform that
pairs you up with your very own Fitness
coach my coach is named Devon he's great
you meet with your coach and you tell
them what you want for me I don't want
to get like buff but like I want to be
able to like lift my body and like be
like wrong and not have back pain and he
designed a fullblown like workout and he
can customize it and change it and I
communicate with him there's no
decision-making here you press go and it
guides you through your workout with
little video examples so you know
exactly what you're supposed to do for
exactly how long and then you move on to
the next thing over the months your
workout will change as you give feedback
to your personal coach who's always
tinkering with it based on what you want
to do what you don't like what you like
it turns out that accountability is
basically the key to keeping a workout
routine like having someone to sound
accountable to and that's the major
benefit to this in my mind is like
there's a real human being who's like
checking in on me are you working out
but it's also really nice to have a
professional like taking all the
guesswork out of my workouts so co-pilot
is awesome I'm grateful for them
sponsoring today's video I'm grateful
they exist I'm grateful that I can like
do 10 pull-ups now because of them and
if you want to try this out there's a
nice sweet discount that they are giving
to all the viewers of my channel if they
click the link in the description and
they sign up before February 1st you get
14 days for free to try this out with
your own personalized coach see if it
works for you and 20% off your first
month so you can try it out at a
discount see if it works for you but
again use the link in my description
because doing so gets you the discount
it helps support the channel and um do
it before February 1st okay that's it
let's dive in to this story about
supplements
it's easy to look at stuff like this and
say it's kind of like medicine and so it
would be kind of regulated like medicine
tracked and vetted by our government's
health agency like medicine is but
medicine goes through a very different
process a super linky process with tons
of studies and clinical trials paperwork
it takes years and years and a lot of
drugs aren't ever even approved they
fail this process and never make it on
to the Shelf but supplements don't have
to do any of that companies are
responsible for ensuring their products
are safe and in fact can often put new
dietary supplements on the market
without even telling FDA There are rules
on what supplement companies are allowed
to put in their pills and gummies but
these rules aren't enforced in any real
way it's up to the supplement company to
obey them with dietary supplements it's
on the honor System that they are
following those rules and regulations
that's Dr C Michael White a pharmacist
disting English professor and chair of
Pharmacy practice at the University of
Connecticut School of Pharmacy and this
is Dr F Perry Wilson I'm a physician and
researcher here at Yale University these
two doctors helped us a lot in our
reporting helped us navigate this really
complex topic and helped us better
understand how this $50 billion a year
industry runs wild with all of these
products that make Health claims that
are often not backed up by
anything there's a wild story on how we
got here and to understand it we have to
go back to the ' 80s and 90s to
understand this political commercial
featuring Mel Gibson and health
supplements it's only
vitamins Nelson Mandela got a rousing
welcome from the city of New York today
the East German authorities have said
the Berlin Wall doesn't mean anything
anymore the '90s was a time of economic
Prosperity In America which fueled the
rise of a health conscious middle class
that was increasingly attracted to
health foods and fitness regime and
alternative medicine I avoid sugar that
makes me feel good about me to cater to
this shift you have the supplement
industry which was very small and Niche
at the time but they met the demand of
this new middle class and began
diversifying their offerings they
expanded beyond the typical vitamin C
tablets and eonia drops introducing a
variety of new substances each
purporting to enhance one's life in
unique ways one of the supplements that
gained popularity was called L
tryptophan
it was this health food supplement made
of amino acids that claimed to help
people sleep and lose weight it sounded
healthy enough until doctors found that
people who took the stuff were
developing blood and muscle disorders
investigations found that it led to the
death of 38 people in response to this
incident Congress began drafting laws
that would tighten regulation on health
supplements so they drafted this bill
the bill would give more power to the
FDA to regulate these companies to
tighten the rules on how supplements
were able to be labeled what claims they
could make but as we know whenever
there's a growing industry that's making
a lot of money off of selling things and
the government comes in and tries to
regulate them they don't just sit back
and let it happen so all the supplement
companies got together they held these
emergency meetings they sent an army of
lobbyists to Washington and they started
pouring money on commercials help make
sure your child gets a balanced diet
with Flintstones and this is where Mel
Gibson the 9s movie star comes into the
[Music]
story hey guys got only vitamins vitamin
C you know like in oranges if you don't
want to lose your vitamins make the FDA
stop yeah they weren't messing around
here they published books they sent
Flyers to people's mailboxes they
produced more commercials they created
petitions to Rally Americans around
their supplements and it worked more and
more Americans were taking supplements
and they responded to this potential
tightening of regulation in all of this
fearmongering by the lobbyists by
writing to Congress telling the
government not to regulate supplements
to let them keep their vitamins at the
same time these lobbyists targeted the
lawmakers themselves convincing them to
oppose the legislation that was under
consideration in Congress and to
actually counter it by passing their own
law a law that would be friendly to the
industry and you can actually see this
point blank sometimes lobbying is like
foggy and we don't know what happen but
in this case the Senators who received
the most money from the industry were
the ones who actually drafted the new
bill for this law and here it is public
law 103 417 from October 25th 1994 so
what started as an attempt to regulate
supplements actually turned into a law
that is friendly to the industry and the
reason we have
this
I mean I love when you're like neck deep
in one of these laws and you just see a
statement that just makes it so clear
like who was influencing this law check
this out this law just straight up says
that the federal government should not
take any actions to impose unreasonable
regulatory barriers towards this
industry and especially says the law
this industry is really lucrative it has
annual sales of $4 billion Congress
wouldn't want to slow that down so then
the big kicker here one of the key parts
of the law is that they specify that
supplements the thing in this bottle is
not classified as medicine it's
classified as food that's how the FDA
should treat it as food but supplements
are not food in the same way a bag of
Doritos is food they're much more
complicated but we'll get back to that
in a sec the point is that this law gave
the industry a lot of freedom including
what kind of claims they could make the
law gave them the authority to say a lot
of things about what their health
supplement does for people as long as
they include this one disclaimer I'm
looking at genius mushrooms the product
says that it is healthy immune system
support energy and Clarity sounds great
but then here on the back in very very
very small teeny tiny almost illegible
font let zoom in here you will see a
teeny tiny statement that complies with
the law these statements have not been
EV valued by the food administrator this
product is not intended to diagnos it's
like right there in the fine print that
no one is reading what people are
reading is this healthy immune system
support energy and Clarity I mean the
law is so friendly to the industry it
allows these companies to effectively
regulate themselves the law makes it
clear that it's the government's job to
go prove that something is adulterated
or wrong rather than making the
companies prove that their products are
safe before they go to market Market I
mean it's totally backwards we do not
approve them for safety and
Effectiveness before they are sold
companies are responsible for ensuring
their products are
safe so thanks to this 1994 law
supplement makers were very happy
because now they don't have to tell the
FDA anything they don't have to prove
that their claims are effective they
just have to put a little tiny fine
print disclaimer and the FDA has no real
enforcement regime they only really step
in in a big way after the supplement is
proven to be hurting people any
Authority they do have to check on these
supplements has to be done with their
shoestring budget this was Congress
giving the supplement industry a blank
check telling them they can do what you
want we can't regulate you it's now the
law and this is why the industry went
from a $4 billion industry in the early
'90s to a $53 billion industry
today this is why Americans are now
inundated with capsules and pills and
drops and creams and teas that claim to
make your body work better but this is
confusing because supplements actually
do have a place in our lives for certain
people who need certain things that
their body can't make so one of my
questions going into all of this is like
what of this is legit is any of it or is
it all just snake
oil what does the science actually
say
[Music]
there's been a lot of good study on this
and luckily we got one of those amazing
things where they do a study of all of
the studies and they put it all together
and they say this is what all the
studies have concluded over the years
like a good old meta analysis this meta
analysis which used 84 studies and put
it all together to find conclusions
found that vitamins and supplements were
generally quote associated treated with
little or no benefit in preventing
cancer cardiovascular disease and death
had a little bit of a benefit on
treating cancer if you already have it
they also found that people with a high
risk of lung cancer had an quote
increased risk of lung cancer and other
harmful outcomes by taking one vitamin
beta katene so what this basically is
saying is that vitamins don't work for
like the big things preventing The
Killers like cancer and heart problems
and they maybe even hurt us in some
cases depending on the supplement but in
reading these conclusions you start to
realize just how complex this is there
are like thousands of different
supplements and there are like
innumerable numbers of individual bodies
that have different chemistry and
different experiences it starts to get
confusing to find a satisfying
conclusion so we asked our experts do
supplements actually make us healthier
in any way many doctors would suggest
that you don't need to take supplements
at all unless you have a deficiency ah
deficiency that's the key word here so
like maybe my body doesn't naturally
produce enough vitamin C or I don't get
it in my food then a supplement would be
useful if you're a strict vegan you have
you know very strong dietary
restrictions for whatever reason those
people probably are good candidates for
taking a multivitamin that's a situation
where it makes a lot of sense but most
of us don't need to do that whenever
there's a situation where all the humans
in a society need a certain substance
that they're not getting the government
goes wild to make it happen like there
was a time when we all were deficient in
iodine so to fix this the government
worked with salt makers to just put
iodine in salt so now all of us use it
all the time and we just have enough
iodine because there's iodine in all of
our salts I guess what I'm saying here
is that most of us check off all of our
vitamins and mineral needs by living and
eating a variety of foods but of course
within our population there are people
who can't produce enough of a certain
vitamin or like this YouTuber who just
ate chicken tenders every single day I
mean they should probably take some
vitamins like you have to eat a variety
of foods to get all your vitamins and
minerals and luckily here in the 21st
century we have a test to find out how
you're doing on this it's a blood test
they take your blood they test it and
they find out how you're doing on
vitamins and minerals and what you might
be deficient in and thus what
supplements might actually work for you
and yet
252 million Americans are popping 53
billion worth of supplements every year
and most of them probably don't need to
be taking anything okay so if I don't
need all this but I'm taking Like A
Fistful of vitamins every day where does
it all go you're just peeing out all of
the excess and it might give you glow
in-the-dark urine which is uh which is
pretty cool but it's it's a it's a large
waste of your dollars here's a full
disclosure that may be surprising to you
I take vitamins and supplements
sometimes like I got sent this green
powder from like a sponsor who's like
thinking about sponsoring a video on the
channel and I totally drank it like
every day it's like a vitamin supplement
has like a billion different vitamins in
it and I was like maybe I need one of
these even though my blood test doesn't
say I do what if I actually do what if
it's actually going to help and I tell
you that to let you know that like this
isn't easy this is not an easy thing to
navigate we're hit with all of these
messages of like improve your mental
Clarity like
increased energy and you're just like is
any of this real what I'm finding is
that most of it is not but what to me is
ethically wrong is when people turn to
supplements because they've been lied to
or because they don't trust or can't
afford other forms of treatment in other
words when they're desperate surveys of
American sentiment show that
pharmaceutical companies have lower
approval ratings than Congress which is
you know that's pretty bad and again in
many ways rightly so the profit tearing
off medications is you know in my
opinion quite unethical so we hate
pharmaceutical companies for good reason
maybe but we suddenly trust supplement
companies We Trust vitamins and the
industry that makes them okay so just
quick recap supplements are the wild
west in the United States they've been
very poorly regulated the industry's
gone wild they can make these wild
claims and a lot of us are maybe wasting
our money and peeing out supplements
that we don't need is that at the scope
of the problem here just that we're
wasting our money and we're being
falsely advertised to doesn't seem that
bad that is Until you realize that not
all supplements are harmless the law
says that supplements should be
regulated like food but they aren't food
there's a lot of complicated work that
goes into creating a highquality safe
supplement it's a complex process of
manufacturing making sure that the
substances are pure the dosage is
correct and it can go go wrong very
easily 23,000 people a year in fact go
to the emergency room after taking a
supplement supplement makers don't have
to prove that their products are safe it
was unbelievable what we found false and
unsubstantiated claims remember El
tryptophan back in like the'80s people
were taking it and they were thinking it
was going to help with their insomnia
and helping them lose weight and yet it
caused thousands of illnesses and dozens
of deaths one of the big problems with
that was likely due to contamination
with within the supplement not
necessarily the substance itself a few
years ago there was a supplement that
came out that was supposed to regulate
blood circulation but it ended up having
lead in it it caused all sorts of lead
poisoning and two deaths a few years
later the FDA seized 300,000 dietary
supplements because they had an
excessive amount of lead in them that
was from one Corporation the FDA isn't
monitoring all of these supplements but
luckily scientists are there's this 2018
study that found that
92% of the supplements that they studied
had bacterial contamination and 87% had
fungal contamination which can be really
damaging for your body I'm not going to
go down a whole like literature review
here because there's so much of this
let's just say there's a lot of
instances of supplements being found to
be
contaminated okay let me just tell you
one more example here that is just such
a good example of the abuse of the lack
of Regulation here there's this one
plant called katum I don't know here in
the US I like feel like I see it
everywhere in every strip mall it's like
Crum signs it's made from this evergreen
tree leaf and it's sold in the form of
powder and pills and extracts it sounds
totally natural and fresh and I can see
why it's doing so well on the market but
once again katum has been linked to
hundreds of cases of salmonella
poisoning and there's the fact that it's
highly addictive especially to those who
have had opioid oid addictions which is
if you haven't heard a giant problem in
our country it has been deemed to be the
cause of death for 91 people who had
overdoses in 2016 and 2017 though only
seven of those people were found to only
have katum in their body there were
other drugs in the overdose as well but
what we're saying here is that this can
be dangerous stuff it's not just food
like the law wants it to be the FDA
urged the DEA to classify this as a
schedule one drug which is the
classification for heroin but it's a
dietary supplement just like down the
road at the local convenience store
speaking of drugs some supplements are
kind of just like drugs in Disguise so
what we're really seeing is that in a
lot of those cases they're putting in
synthetic drugs which sometimes are
prescription drugs and sometimes are
products that are not approved by the
FDA one study found that over the last
decade more than 750 supplements were
illegally spiked with with drugs only
half of them were ever recalled wait why
can they do this why can they just put
drugs like illegal drugs into
supplements ah because of this law this
law that the industry helped pass in the
9s that says that none of this has to
get any approval from the FDA the FDA
only steps in when something goes wrong
when like the damage is already done so
backwards and these companies can get
pretty aggressive a few years ago the
academics who revealed that these
supplement companies were spiking their
supplements with illegal drugs got sued
by one of these companies a company
called high-tech Pharmaceuticals the
company ended up losing the lawsuit but
what it revealed is that this company
had been selling a product that they had
been ordered to stop selling to recall
and they just never did like there's so
little oversight happening here and
again it's a giant industry with a lot
of money and a lot of products and it's
an FDA that is very small with very
little money and not a lot of authority
to do much and as we mentioned at the
very beginning of the video when
researchers went in and just like popped
open some of these bottles and studied
the pills they found that a lot of these
supplements don't actually have what
they say they have like they're a
totally different substance but none of
us know because you don't know what
calcium tastes like literally there have
been SES that have shown some
supplements have have no detectable
amount of the thing that it says is
supposed to be in there no detectable
amount and then we've got good old
melatonin I love melatonin when I need
it that gummy that helps us all get a
good night's sleep but it's not a
sleeping pill right because it's like
natural melatonin poisonings in children
have been on the rise over the past
decade well actually melatonin is not a
vitamin it is a hormone that you
naturally produce it helps induce sleep
and it's kind of been trending over the
last few years especially among children
over the past decade the number of
children who have over overdosed on
melatonin went up
530 causing kids to experience symptoms
like vomiting and diarrhea a lot of that
is because of dosage problems in some
cases they found that the dose is 50%
higher than what was on the label the US
Food and Drug Administration doesn't
have any control of the ingredients or
the accuracy of dosage claims we talked
to one guy who started a Reddit for him
because he was taking Lion's man which
is a mushroom supplement and it was
causing a mysterious illness he thought
it was going to give him energy and
mental Clarity like it says on the
bottle but instead what he experienced
was heart palpitations sleepless nights
I couldn't sleep for 8 months straight
by that I say one more than one or two
hours a night when he started the
subreddit he found thousands of others
who reported a whole host of
neurological issues chronic tension
headaches a lack of emotion one user's
husband took his life after not being
able to sleep having constant panic
attacks and losing his job over it he
was
43 i' been to the hospital about 20
times the first two months I have seen
basically every specialist that I could
get a hold of and really nobody could
tell me what was going on these people
come to Reddit because they don't have
any answers they bought a supplement
that looked legitimate promising mental
Clarity and focus and energy and had
their lives completely changed that's
because our government failed we have a
government to protect us against exactly
these types of things but instead people
are turning to Reddit to find answers to
me this is the most atrocious version of
supplements we actually reached out to
the FDA as a part of this story to
understand like what's the deal why is
it like this and they responded and we
scheduled an interview we were going to
discuss dietary supplements and
regulation in the United States but then
the day before the interview they canel
our meeting and then just ghosted
us luckily we have clips of former FDA
Commissioners talking about this and
they all seem to agree that this is a
problem of authority and resources will
the FDA ever regulate this
industry we
tried so what can be done here well
luckily we live in a system where we can
make change
by changing laws like in the 9s we
almost did this if the Congress had
given the FDA more power we would have
stricter punishments for supplement
companies who break the rules we would
have better rules around what they can
sell and what claims they can make we
should at least be able to agree that
all the companies should have to prove
that they don't have bacterial or fungal
contamination that they don't have heavy
metals that they're not containing
prescription drugs and that they do
contain the product in the dose that's
specified in the pills that they're
putting on their label I would like
Purity and that people know what they're
getting I mean we owe it to Consumers at
the very least that if you're going to
choose to buy it you should at least
know what you're getting that seems like
the bare minimum and right now that's
not the case the experts we talked to
don't think that supplements should be
regulated like drugs I think that makes
sense but they agree that we should
start with giving the FDA the authority
and the resources it needs to monitor
supplements so we know what's actually
in them so that we're not trusting the
honor System of for-profit companies to
obey the rules and to actually put in
these supplements what they say is in
these supplements this would mean the
FDA going and conducting spot checks
more often and more aggressively to make
sure that this stuff is correct and that
it's being manufactured in a clean way
free of contamination Congress has
recently considered a bill that would
help with this including trying to
create a database of all the supplements
so that the FDA is at least knows what's
on the market but of course the
supplement Lobby is not going to stand
back they spend over $2 million a year
on lobbying making sure that things stay
the way they are they make a lot of
money off it so if you are one of the
many millions who take a bunch of
supplements and are not sure if they're
spiked with weird stuff or if you even
need them what do you do and the answer
is go get your blood tested and just see
if you're deficient in anything if you
actually need a dietary supplement and
even if your blood test comes back and
you don't need anything I believe that
people should be able to consume
whatever they want even if it's not
scientifically proven you know your body
you should be able to take whatever
vitamin or mineral you feel is working
for you I just think that when you have
a for-profit industry that is free to
mislead and deceive and prey on
consumers you get a bunch of bad
situations like the ones we've talked
about here so until the government steps
in to help us navigate this we're kind
of on our own I'm going to put some
links in the descript description to
third party websites that you can go to
to look up your supplements the specific
supplements and see if they've passed a
highquality standard to know if at least
you're getting what it says on the
bottle so that's where we're at with
supplements we're here waiting for
transparency and accountability and
above all waiting for the regard of
others well-being over the interests of
an industry that seems to care more
about profit than about our
health
thanks for watching the video everyone
thank you co-pilot for sponsoring
today's video co-pilot found that people
are nine times more likely to stick with
a workout routine if they're actually
accountable to a human being that checks
in with me that asks me how it's going
that makes all of the difference there
is a link in my description it gives you
14 days for free with your own personal
health and fitness coach so you can try
it out for free see if it works and
cancel if it doesn't work and stick with
it if it does thanks to all of our
supporters over at The Newsroom which is
our patreon I deeply appreciate your
support every month for those who want
to learn more there's a link in the
description we sell Luts and presets
which is how we color our videos and
photos I have a poster that is a bunch
of maps that's really fun and we started
a new channel called search party with
my old colleague Sam Ellis and it's
really good that's all thanks for being
here see
[Music]
you
n